Edmonton thank you for more of that
north of the Border love y'all show me
another great time it was good to be
back there as well Chicago you're up
next November 11th and the 12th Grand
Rapids December 9th and the 10th get
your tickets to those shows on my
website at ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social medias and I want to say what I
say every week and that's thank you
thank you for your support however you
support me however you support this show
I just want to Simply say thank you for
real it makes a difference in my life
alright
um if you're watching this subscribe on
YouTube
um if you're listening subscribe to the
audio and if you gotta have more you
gotta check out my patreon it's the
wildest show on patreon it's the
Honeydew with y'all and we highlight the
low lights with y'all and that's why
it's the wildest nobody's got stories
like you all right it is staying five
dollars a month if you want a year
sign up for it you'll save over a month
all right you get the Honeydew a day
early ad free at no additional cost it's
one level it's five bucks all right and
if I'm in your town
when you're around come on out and see
me I got two more dates left this year
we're gonna do Chicago November 11th and
12th we're gonna do Grand Rapids
December 9th and 10th and then I'm gonna
take some time off with the family and
enjoy things all right now you guys know
what we do over here we highlight the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers uh
ladies and gentlemen it is a pleasure to
have this guest officially back on the
Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Prof welcome back to the
Honeydew young man
hey so can you see me ladies and
gentlemen
make sure make sure that camera's right
[Laughter]
thanks for having me
we deserve that yeah we deserve good to
be seen it's good to be seen you know
seen and heard is good or at least we
had the audio Yeah so if you didn't see
uh prof's last episode we had one
um and unfortunately the video was was
lost not only yours but Fortune
feamsters also same day so I had to call
both you and tell you that the only time
it's ever happened in all these years it
was [ __ ] we honeydew I thought
something was super wrong you're like
look
I was like oh my God
what burned down or like what what do
you need for me I'm like what could this
dude possibly be sweating on like when
you know the it's like the worst news
possible like you know I thought
something was really really really wrong
and then you're just you know
from Minnesota you came here for that
it's the first look I had to you know
I think I did some other [ __ ] that week
or something I don't know you might have
who knows but you came here for it and
thank you for being [ __ ] so cool
about it and thank you for coming back I
don't cry over spilled milk I hear you
on that yeah uh but I busted a nut man
we went over all the crazy [ __ ] like so
if if you got time to listen to the
audio and you want to hear like that was
all my best [ __ ] dude I threw it all on
the table so today we're probably not
going to speak we're just gonna just sit
here look at each other but
that was some good [ __ ] so go go back
and look at you talked about growing up
as well one of or or the only white
family in in your hood yeah there was it
was it was me there was one other family
for sure you know but it was it was
mostly a predominantly black
neighborhood but there was you know we
have a lot of thriving Mexican community
and everything like that so talked about
your dad fighting your sister's
boyfriend my dad was crazy
burn my house down quick quick recap of
all the horrible [ __ ]
um he was bipolar you know fight fight
my suit
like that and then um yeah I don't know
I don't know that was that's about a
quick summary of the the bad [ __ ] I love
the [ __ ] dad fighting the daughter's
boyfriends I hope I can do that [ __ ] one
day yeah we might have to do that but
more is like sanction like Hey we're
gonna go on a workout like we're gonna
go work out like in a gym yeah I mean
here's these boxes we were smart about
it yeah this was some like backyard [ __ ]
he was really whooping the [ __ ] out of
these kids you know but
that's my guy R.I.P oh [ __ ] all right
well please plug and promote everything
you'd like to before we get into this
episode just do it up nah you did that
last time too and then it happened right
there you're like you know
I will say this Kirkland [ __ ]
y'all need to do the right thing
do what's right before it's going to be
troubled
you know what I'm saying you don't
[ __ ] smoke with me when I said I
needed a sponsorship I [ __ ] needed
one
so
whatever man you need to do the right
thing
cheers all right you wrap them hard
well it depends it's all up to them it's
all up to them now they can have it
whatever way they want why a Kirkland
well
you know I think that they just need
someone like me like a brand ambassador
I've never seen a better fit you know
semi-violent you know kind of like yeah
yeah but still I you know can pass kind
of semi-white and you know you know do
do something like that you know but safe
but a little bit dangerous kind of funny
you know and that screams Kirkland yeah
this is just me it's just it just fits
right to the soul no I mean it's
obviously very sarcastic but yeah
I wore this I wore this one some I've
won one post on IG and I was just
talking [ __ ] to him like man y'all gonna
[ __ ] get it you don't sponsor me you
know I'm saying just threatening them
and then I went on tour and everybody
was wearing these Kirkland brand shirts
like in the audience I was like oh [ __ ]
maybe they do need to sponsor me no you
just turn those into profland shirts
yeah yeah they're not gonna sponsor you
borrowed a [ __ ] just take their whole
[ __ ] take it start their whole I thought
you were a gangster you take that [ __ ]
um
all right over here debating with
Kirkland they see you this time they'll
see me this time
see me yeah I mean I don't want to plug
nothing man it's just all right well
then you know what I'm telling me
there's so much okay listen I just want
to be thankful that I'm here today
because this airport story is real
you're just asking me oh do you get
recognized yeah yeah I mean how often I
mean it's what I was asking outside
depends on where I mean right
I mean you know I just toured the
country and sold out
live shows I've seen I don't know how
you do it it was the [ __ ] it was a
really really good show in La so you
know uh I could get recognized in every
single city in the country because I've
been there 10 times
performing but you know Minneapolis is
different you know like some markets are
just bigger Denver's really big uh the
Northwest is really big and it's just
always growing you know and so that's
why I love the mask mandates
I just threw a mask on like all I was
like I wore the [ __ ] out of it I don't
care if I was getting sick or not put a
hat on and I was out in free Freedom
going to the zoo with my family and [ __ ]
like no one was coming up to me like you
know it was dope so like I was I held on
to the mask thing for as long as I could
just for that reason
um but in La it's just people you know I
was at the comedy store they just what's
up keep it moving but anyway so I'm in
I'm in the airport
I'm going through I'm I'm in security
and the dude behind me oh what's up Prof
you know I'm saying I'm like yeah you
know I I just my anxiety is high you
take the shoes off you want to be faster
this [ __ ] so I'm like oh and he's you
know looking at my shoes looking at you
know my my backpack and seeing the
things and before I leave I'm getting
dropped off I look back in the car I go
we'll see what kind of shit's left over
in my backpack you know
I'm like see you when I get back and hit
my shoes my computer goes over this way
and then my backpack goes to the special
special line and then it's just like
don't
them and the fan behind me is like oh
like I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm thinking like
what the [ __ ] is it you know and you
know when you're like okay you have
something either dangerous or very
valuable you're like I'm gonna put this
somewhere really safe so safe that I
completely forget about it
so not only that I forgot that zipper
that pouch was in it well dude I forget
it all the time so I forget about these
little ones so it's going over there and
the dude's going this is you dead or
that I'm like yeah you know dude's like
[ __ ] you know and I think you know
people he's with us talking about me
but now I'm I'm my heart's pounding just
thinking about it bro
so I still don't know what it is it's
going through my head I'm like
let's come over here and it's not a
private room he's doing it right like
he's behind the glass but everybody gets
to see it and he's like opening I'm like
oh yeah oops I forgot to take the I have
big headphones out uh you know
Electronics I'm like oh yeah it was them
I'm I'm mixing and mastering my record
it's coming out pretty soon plug it and
then um so I just realized you're saying
that to the camera I thought you were
saying it to the TSA oh yeah hi
everybody I'm mixing and mastering my
records huh
and I know it's not the [ __ ]
headphones you know he's like no that's
not what I'm after I'm like oh [ __ ] and
he goes into the case and then he opens
then there's this one zipper
and then I go
you knew you remember when you talk
about your [ __ ] clenching and [ __ ]
like
I just flashed all over my [ __ ] boy
[ __ ] went like a [ __ ] like a drop
like a drawstring like like in a
backpack
bow and I just flashed red and I was
like
he lifted it up I got caught at the
airport with two bags of LSD and a box
cutter
I swear to God
what did they do and then oh we just
pulled both baggies up like this
everyone's like you know you're hearing
gasps and [ __ ] I'm like yes I'm like oh
that oh I for I'm I forgot about that I
forgot about that that's um
where does your head go I'm like you can
have that bro you could just just let
just let me sit on out yeah I'm talking
I'm like oh I forgot about that like
this is what I'm saying and then he's
he's just not saying [ __ ] and he's
opening I'm like oh my God and he's
looking at everything I'm thinking oh
it's a wrap what's the fan doing mine oh
they're going
you know I'm here I'm just it's just
electric little cackles and [ __ ] it's
just popping electric energy
uh I'm oh this is [ __ ] rap dude I
ain't come down to a later day I'm going
to jail Mike my manager Mike's already
through and everything and I'm like
maybe he'll fly to L.A
so maybe I'll get bailed out at a
certain time where I can still make this
podcast run
so
and this is I take I take LSD
microdosing for like long uh video shoot
days long 12 hour days and [ __ ] and for
me it's like a really good cup of coffee
and it keeps me engaged and focused and
energized for a long time I hear you on
that I just saying for me I can't
imagine something the shrooms make sense
to me but something like LSD it's
amazing Microsoft's very very small
that's why I have my box cutter up there
I mean I'll I'll cut that's what that's
what it was just it was for that yeah
so I'll I'll cut one in like an eighth
barely anything and you know like I'll
those are my productive work days I'll
be working out I'll be doing you know
like you can drive on I can easily drive
on that parent [ __ ] you know that's
what people say about all these things
so I'm curious yeah it's amazing some of
my best workouts I'm like I'm just
zipping by on this [ __ ] bike and I'm
like I've never uh done a workout that
hard spring chicken ass [ __ ] and I'm
like not even breaking a sweat I'm like
What's Next and I'm engaged I want to do
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] fantastic I highly
recommend it
um and I do want to I don't I I do want
to macro dose someday like really blow
my mind out but I haven't even really
done that you know like this is some
really responsible [ __ ] I know I've been
the same way I'm also scared of it too I
I I I I don't know what's up in this
[ __ ] I did I did I did uh
overdose a little bit more my girl was
like I I was on a regimen very uh um I
studied about it and and followed a
doctor's recommendations and everything
and then I had I was like this one's
kind of big she's like take another one
I'm like okay so I'm out driving to
camper world with my family
yeah because we've yeah came across a
week a really old camper and now we own
this some really old campers so anyways
I'm driving do you know if you got
camper worlds down here yeah they're out
here huge American flags yeah so I'm
driving I go
woof I'm like I could get there I ain't
I ain't driving back you're driving back
and I get there and everyone's going
inside I'm looking at this American flag
and it's like so CR I'm like I'm
tripping balls now so if you dose a
little bit more than you're used to like
really small doses if you [ __ ] around
it'll get you and how many a day one a
day oh just one tiny one one eighth of a
one tab a day an eighth of a dose a day
not hourly year no no no no no okay no
it's like nothing okay so and that that
amount is enough for you to feel the
difference
barely yeah sometimes you you can start
me tripping I mean yeah skirt around and
be like ah but I'm just uplifted right
now okay
you know I started in those like four or
five times so small that I didn't feel
anything and you know very very
incremental things you know and even
when you don't feel anything you just go
through your day and you're like you you
know you might have noticed [ __ ] I had a
great day and it's been eight hours and
I've been going I was like well look man
if I need to work out and do cardio for
an hour to stay alive but I could
microdose acid to make that hour feel
like three minutes hopefully not not
five years yeah just do it yeah do it
right well
I'm at the [ __ ] Airport
and so I have a box cutter in there and
it's like it's like an old school one
one with a handle and the whole blade is
sideways so it's like it's like big and
everyone's gasping at me and this dude's
like oh man I'm like
you can have this you know it's not
that's not gonna work you know I'm like
I'm like you got me dude take me
wherever you [ __ ] want to go whatever
and he doesn't say [ __ ] looks at me and
he goes
and he disengages the blade and he holds
this [ __ ] rates of Blade up like that
like he's like he's displaying it to
everybody like he's a [ __ ] magician
dude I I
just got total control of my nuts and
the whole situation everybody's watching
I don't know I don't know if he
recognized me or or what kind of games
he's playing but you know there was an
audience and he was all the way up with
it like this
and he takes the razor blade puts it
down here looks at this you know the the
mechanics and everything
puts it back in the baggies there's two
separate baggies with I don't know why I
have two bags fasted and then what does
the acid look like is it a strip this is
it's interesting yeah you know uh I
don't think a lot of people might not
know what I know liquid I know there's a
bunch of different and there's like
stuff that looks like paper that's just
a tab with a liquid on it but then
there's like plastic [ __ ] that is mine
it looks it's it looks like plastic and
um you have to yeah actually cut it yeah
it looks it looks like tiny tiny chunks
of plastic okay and they press them into
like a machine like a waffle maker yeah
and that's what it was some good [ __ ]
it's one of the last really really good
doses that went through Minneapolis like
that so
[Laughter]
so the magician
doing this thing and I just obviously
was perfect that was being recognized
and I had a huge show with people and
I'm just I'm a white dude my head my
head is red hot my ears are they're
saying guilty you know what I'm saying
I'm all red
and he puts it back into the baggie
slowly you know he's got his gloves on
and everything and then he puts the
baggies back in my pocket
with the box cutter no Zips it and goes
all right you can be on your way all he
did was take the razor blade that's it
and he gave me back all my drugs and he
gave me back my box cutter he just
pulled the box cutter blade was in it
still too no no he took out the blade he
took the blade all right gave me back my
box cutter and my uh
my LSD
and I was just like
I said I said those dudes I knew they
wanted a picture but I was like whoop I
was like oh oh I was like I gotta get
out of here bro and I just [ __ ] I ran
through the airport so it's in the hotel
room if you want to get wild tonight man
I don't know I gotta put it back on my
on my check luggage but
man craziest story ever dude that was
coming here yes just now yes oh [ __ ] I
didn't realize it was this I'm lucky to
be here
I didn't realize it was this this was
this trip that's very recent
hours yesterday dog what do you mean
I'm still fresh off this [ __ ] dude I'll
uh all right I'll trade you one because
I haven't told anybody this
this is a story so I [ __ ] uh this
tour is going on this night pass Nation
Tour whatever and I'm doing my Baltimore
stopping um TSA has said that you're
allowed to fly with an ounce of
marijuana excuse me up to an ounce of
marijuana in your carry on only great I
have clear which ntsa pre-check okay we
go right up to the front of that [ __ ]
line
and I have my daughter with me on this
tool this leg because we're going to see
family and [ __ ] so I throw a couple
packs of joints in my suitcase and we're
rolling through and they [ __ ] the
shoe Baltimore or L.A in L.A going to
Baltimore oh that's me and my daughter
this guy's like this you I'm like yeah
he's like we need to see you down here
I'm like I hate that feeling I got not
this not now not with my kid
with her her mom say some [ __ ] about it
yeah my family's like you're getting
flagged at the airport with weed your
kid you know what I mean I'm like God
damn it Ryan why do you do this [ __ ]
you make [ __ ] up decisions I'm a
[ __ ] weed man come on man so the guys
pulled me over and he just opens the
suitcase up and he's doing the same
thing he's going through everything and
I'm thinking like
and then he touches the weed and I'm
like [ __ ] his [ __ ] pushed it to
the side
here it is all excited it was my
daughter's [ __ ] hairspray he goes you
got that oh [ __ ]
I packed it though and I was like oh
okay I grabbed I couldn't have been
happy I grabbed that here
I [ __ ] threw my daughter's like damn
my hair's pressing shut up we'll get
hairspray at CVS we get there man grab
my [ __ ] Zip Zip to the side that's
exactly kind of like my story inside
dying inside not with my kid dying
inside does she I mean
she's not old enough to be like you
smoke weed or she is now we just have we
just
what are we in now under this whole so a
couple months ago was June I think we
went to visit
um family back in Maryland Ocean City
Maryland one of my really good friends
who we've been friends since sixth grade
his daughter
um got a hot shot in Baltimore and died
in Fentanyl
and he came to visit and I'm asking him
you know how's how's everything going
and so on the ride back we had to go
from Ocean City to Philly it's like two
and a half hours to get to the airport
and so she started asking me about what
happened to his daughter and I was like
and I just had this like I could either
sit here and [ __ ] this [ __ ] kid
or I could tell her the [ __ ] truth
and I was like are you ready for an
adult conversation she's like yeah yeah
I go all right this is what happened and
I told her that some good people
sometimes make bad choices someone that
does bad things isn't always a bad
person and
um but you're about to be in second
grade and I just know drugs are coming
quicker and quicker these kids grab a
Percocet out of their [ __ ] parents
yeah cabinet they don't know whatever
yeah or older brother or some [ __ ] like
that so yeah I told her the truth about
what happened and I told her about
marijuana I told her that it's you know
um it's medicine I told her my doctor's
the one who prescribed it he knows I
smoke it yeah
um I told her you know I changing the
mindset of yeah this [ __ ] isn't bad and
evil this is the good stuff that
cigarette you're smelling over there
that [ __ ] even booze you know trash
that's what I tell her too I'm like nope
so she knows I smoke it she knows what
it is
um and and I mean we live out here dude
there's Billboards everywhere for us
because what's that leaf what's that so
you gotta talk down with that [ __ ] it's
changing you know rather have like you
know we used to grow up with alcoholic
parents whipping the [ __ ] out of us
imagine if we grew up with like some
pothead parents like giggling and
cooking cooking in the kitchen playing
board games eating snacks yeah
we wouldn't be sitting right here dude
I'll tell you that no
um you were gonna tell me some high
school [ __ ] I wanted to hear about you
in high school like oh yeah were you
rapping back then yeah you were so when
did you start that what age what started
probably freshman in high school I
started rapping um it started I was on a
track team I was [ __ ] lightning fast
I hated running [ __ ]
Varsity right away you know running
around on the track team people you know
they saw me I don't know I was
real thing but Buffet Lightning Fast
dude and so we're just 40. do you
remember your 40 time no 100 no I I was
I wasn't good enough sprinting because I
didn't have enough muscle I was fast as
[ __ ] in the two four and eight two four
and eight and uh so four is one full lap
right yep so eight two I hate the 800.
800 is the hardest [ __ ] ever
anyways I hate all running but anyways
we were warming up and we would just be
freestyling and [ __ ] the very first time
I set a rhyme
where I started this eight bar out I
started not knowing anything what I'm
going to say and then it wrapped up
perfectly and it ran perfectly I was
like
ah I just busted a nut I was like that
was so much fun that was like Godly
I just made something out of thin air
didn't exist poof it was wrapped up in a
tight little ball and I was like that's
it for me and then freestyling was like
my [ __ ] [ __ ] and I did it all the
time throughout high school and you know
it was a way to keep me out of like
you know the fast lip fast tongue was my
little knife you know walking around you
know Section 8 type of housing you know
people want it I'll get approached it's
time it's time to with the kids the
neighborhood kids it's time to steal
this [ __ ] bike man what's up dude you
want to come with me
it's just a series of bad decisions you
know what I'm saying it's like sometimes
you don't have a great decision well
maybe if I don't come with you I'm just
getting my ass kicked so would I go with
you guys on some crime spree and you
know they want me to hold a knife and
[ __ ] I'm like so rapping was like let me
just get known for just Clowning on
people and having a sharp tongue so I
started rapping in high school and I was
I was a class clown in high school and
that's how I dealt with just kind of
like navigating being safe you know a
lot of people fell into selling drugs or
like you know whooping [ __ ]
asses like I was always scared to hold a
knife and [ __ ] like that wasn't me so I
just was a Class Clown I had people like
me you know what I mean rather than
going comedians talk about it rather
than going and doing real dirt you know
then oh that's cool profit Jacob you
stupid you know these stupid ass mother
it was like ha cool like that's me you
know but
yeah the high school the high school
times was crazy I was in you know the
teachers knew me they did not want me
you know any class that I was in
especially with my friend daru shakbari
he's out here in LA
if we were in this class together
everybody would transfer to come see us
yes they'd be like what
they were like Jake Jake and dog are in
the same class the class would flood
everybody request would request
transfers just to see us [ __ ] clown
around and [ __ ] it was immaculate it was
amazing it was I was crazy in high
school
yeah
we were talking about pet Fest I think
that's what you want me to get into yeah
you called it Fest y'all call it pep
rally I mean my school was a pep rally
so like you talking about like getting
fired up for like the big Friday Night
Football game or whatever yeah yeah but
we're in a city our football team always
got smashed by the [ __ ] the suburbs
with [ __ ] you know money you know so
it wasn't pep rally or pep Fest for us
was all about just getting together and
like I don't know school spirit or
something no one was we don't give a
[ __ ] about the game because we were
gonna get blown out 48 to seven you know
we had no barely had any [ __ ] pads
you know but pet Fest it was like a
school sanctioned
fist fighting event
I can't believe it looking back at it
like thinking about this how we were
talking 19 well I was a sophomore
2099 maybe 2001 2000. and they would
separate the classes and you every class
would have a different color so there's
your [ __ ] gang [ __ ] like you're those
are the Ops this is us we're blue you're
black you're red and I think I forget
the other one
um and we are sophomores at the time and
it was we'd be on the uh track and field
on bleachers and we would do some
graffiti on a big big long scroll and
represent our class and we are
sophomores and
um and people would try to sneak over to
the other side and tear down your sign
and so we'd be in front of our sign
protecting our [ __ ] and I remember you
know this year I was like this is wild
like a friend of mine Owen I never even
seen him fight before
but he helped with the sign and people
were coming by and he was like all of a
sudden I just look around him wow he was
laying [ __ ]
I'm looking around there's no there's no
teachers around like this is just going
on we're just fist fighting right here
this is just going on and so then I'm
like all right
let's let's protect this [ __ ] and then
one bigger girl came over and we were
able to like all band together and lift
her over this fence she must have been
300 pounds over this fence
and onto the track so that's kind of
like out of our area so anybody came
through like and the whole the whole
bleachers were behind us like yeah so we
there's a couple soldiers down here in
the pit like totally amped up
and you know getting a lot of juice from
who's behind us and some people were
coming around and we would band together
do some fighting and [ __ ] and then throw
somebody over
this one guy came through and he was
dressed in black all black that's all
senior colors
and he had [ __ ] facial hair
so I'm like
seeing you that's another that's a new
level whatever but he was he was little
he's littler than me and he just came
through really really rugged pushing me
really hard ready to fight like way in
my space and I'm like okay let's get
this dude and I remember being like
we've done this before we're getting
good at it at this time and poor guy he
turned out to be a freshman but he had a
[ __ ] beard and he was dressing all
black so
does I don't know if it really matters
for if he was a freshman or a senior
because we were going to throw him over
the fence and break his arm
regardless of
what grade he was in so I've reached
down there and I grabbed him like this
and I'm and he's struggling and [ __ ] and
people enjoyed what happened last so now
everybody wants to get a hand on it and
it's getting more and more hectic and we
easily get him up above like this and
it's not like three or four people
anymore they all of a sudden like it
started with just me and by the time he
was like up to here I felt like there
was
15 hands
and so we're like right now it's time
we're like here we go and it was the it
was the lightest like you know when you
over compensate for something like oh
[ __ ] it just it was way different than
just dropping someone over it was like
boom and all of a sudden he was no lie
15 20 [ __ ] feet in the air
going like ah I'm just slow motion look
at him like oh my God you know and he's
going like this and then he just goes
What lands like this with his arms
oh it was a tossaburra body
and then the whole place was just wild
really really loud and it was like ah it
was like crickets and all you heard was
this poor kid
[Applause]
dead quiet we all ran
a gang fight and I apologize
yeah this is a school event
yeah that is ridiculous and so I'm like
I I always laugh oh [ __ ] goes down I'm
like huh and then the inter the police
get come through they interrogate
everybody and everybody ought to
bleachers just sees me turn around and
go oh [ __ ] you know I was loud and and
so they just definitely singled me out
and uh I got some big trouble for that
one what happened to the kid snap that
arm he really [ __ ] he yeah he Tom
secured himself for sure he was he was
[ __ ] up for a long time snapped the
arm in a few different places and he was
in a cast like I remember I like they
were trying to expel me but I'm like you
know too good looking so so it didn't
work out so it was like really awkward
when I would see him at school yeah did
they get the side
no no one got this
sorry about your arm bro nobody got that
sign
Tom still has trouble opening his hand
oh man is that kid probably had problems
I ran into him again just super randomly
no I I I uh and if if that dude I mean
he's a grown man now I apologize man you
know it's I never met him until that
point it wasn't you know I always felt
bad about that you know did you ever get
a moment with him yes I did it was so
[ __ ] weird I was in a doing some rap
[ __ ] in some sort of office or some
podcast thing you know a decade later or
whatever and we want to go down the
elevator is going down and just me and
my dudes like looking all brutish and
thuggish like I don't know what we were
doing
and the elevator opens up it's like ding
and it's just I'm in front and it's just
him and I'm just looking at him and you
reckon it because he was a friend when
he saw him Bing we both knew he knew who
root was right away not a word was said
all that all that silence and it was he
got in deep I know I stood there I
didn't go in he was already in there he
was in Alabama
and the dude like all my guys are like
what was that I like thing
thing that was it I saw him like 10
years later and that was that was so
never a word never a word the elevator
went down we went down next elevator and
he was not there you know I don't think
he wanted to talk to me
you know so
yeah then yeah then then pet Fest and
pep rally was canceled in Minneapolis
for like maybe maybe it never happened
after that
you know yeah sorry about that y'all
but it was definitely canceled after
that
yeah the struggles we faced with our
mental health can Loom large over our
lives maybe yours may be someone you
love you've tried everything or have you
mind Bloom is the solution for the next
chapter in mental health and well-being
mind Bloom is the leader in at-home
ketamine therapy offering a combination
of science-backed Medicine with
clinician and guide support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being mind Bloom connects
patients to licensed psychiatric
clinicians to help them achieve better
outcomes with lower costs greater
convenience and an artfully crafted
experience to begin take mind Bloom's
online assessment to determine if mind
Bloom is right for you if approved
you'll schedule a video consult with a
licensed clinician where you'll discuss
your goals and expectations for mental
health treatment mind Bloom will send
you a kit in the mail complete with
medicine treatment materials and tips
for getting the most out of your
experience after only two sessions 87
percent of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements depression and 85 percent
reported improvements in anxiety it's
time to enter the next chapter in mental
health and well-being let mind Bloom
guide you right now mind Bloom is
offering my listeners a hundred dollars
off your first six session program when
you sign up at mindbloom.com Honeydew
and use promo code honeydew at checkout
go to mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew for 100 off your first six
session program today that's
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew now let's get back to the do
um tell me about I want to hear about
South by Southwest oh yeah I don't want
to go I don't ever want to go there
again man I've been once well I just
want to stop by Southwest once but we
were just in Austin it changed you know
what I'm saying it was it was a really
cool place for like bands to get
discovered you know [ __ ] 50 years ago
now it's like you went to Pepsi stage
that's shaped in a [ __ ] like a
Doritos bag and with Kanye playing like
you know there's no chance for
knew about coming acts you know that
that's a farce you know I'm saying it's
just a [ __ ] high-priced music
festival with just lines and clout just
nasty stinky clout you know so like you
know I I did go there a few years in a
row you know trying to grind it out and
[ __ ] and just sleep on someone's couch
and [ __ ] like back in the day and there
was some cool shows
um but now [ __ ] oh I'm not playing
South by first time I didn't play South
by Southwest you're like we don't have
any offers I'm like yes
but the one time in South by Southwest
we went had a show in um San Antonio
because I don't know they were doing
that too they're trying to get involved
in it ate tilapia
for dinner and that completely [ __ ]
destroyed me the worst food poisoning I
ever got in my life were salmonella or
whatever the [ __ ] it was I've been there
I know what you're talking about and
there was a show that night and we just
have a little rental car all my homies
was with they're like you know we were
young and active let's go do some stuff
before the show and I'm like I'm sitting
in this car I'm like
starting to sweat starting to like get
nauseous I'm like man I'm tired man
I gotta I gotta sit in this car man so I
remember sitting in the car and being
like just
hot sweat spit you know spitty like all
right now I gotta do this show and I
held it down the throw up and I wish
I wish I can throw I can't throw up is
the problem is that right yes what do
you mean you can't a weird thing
happened in high school you know last
time I threw up I got really [ __ ]
drunk I got super high and I like lit a
ping pong ball on fire and tried to
smoke it and it was some weird whites
like it like I inhaled it and I was got
really plastic yeah I I had yeah there's
some funny [ __ ] and I inhaled it and I
was like super sick and I threw up and I
was really sick and then after that I
would just my body was like oh shut it
down and I've been trying to because if
you could throw up that's a good start
for some to get some [ __ ] out of you
when you can't throw up [ __ ] you're
sick for five or six days you're
[ __ ] it out like it's gonna go all
the way in your muscles and every single
organ and [ __ ] and so I did the show I
barely got over that show wait come back
to this [ __ ] smoking a ping pong ball
like they [ __ ] you up that much huh
that plastic yeah don't smoke ping pong
balls
oh
[Music]
well
um of course it was a joke I wasn't
trying to get but that poison really
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] me up wow it changed
my body chemistry forever
forever yeah wow so I'm not positive
even at this time at South by Southwest
I do the show and I'm like now we got to
drive back to Austin and I have like
seven shows in three days I still gotta
ask another question yeah what do you
mean you can't throw up your body will
lock it will not allow it like you've
never hit to the point where it just
[ __ ] comes out I'm driving like oh
come on I'm sweating it comes out around
I'm like please I'm like trying to push
as hard as I can but there's like I get
all the way I mean
all the worst [ __ ] about throwing up I
still do except the the good [ __ ] you
can't go there mentally and like start
just tasting it mentally I want I I want
to you gotta dig deep I've tried so hard
I got like I'll coach you next time all
right just hold my hair back
you got this Prof come on now think
about waterfalls
yeah man it's all right sorry I'll stop
it around so I can't throw up I'm in San
Antonio it's [ __ ] cracking I'm like I
need to throw I know this is a really
bad what's ever coming in my body and I
know I have like four or five days
really hard work ahead at the top by
Southwest I'm like
I need to find ipecac you know that [ __ ]
that makes you throw up because I know I
can't and I've never had it before
that's just my only idea and I'm like yo
go to any you know CVS or uh Walgreens
whatever the [ __ ] it is I need to get
this ipicac and so we like put it in a
GPS and we like it's like some party on
the [ __ ]
River Walk have you been to San Antonio
no but I know it's on the Riverwalk so
I'm on a Riverwalk it's [ __ ] Saturday
night people are like going crazy I'm
like delusional I'm I'm uh things are
blurry and [ __ ] and we and uh they're
like you have to get out this car right
now because it's somewhere down on the
Riverwalk we can't go down there so I'm
like by myself like everybody's partying
and [ __ ] I'm sweating like ah straight
poison I get up to [ __ ] Walgreens
they're like oh we just like sold a lot
you know we don't have any more and I'm
like
that was my last chance at this and so
then I was sick and I did like seven
shows in like three days in Austin some
grimy ass nasty little bars you know not
like oh there's a nice backstage with
your own public toilet private toilet
like this is like this bar has been
thrown up and partied in for five days
here's a little six inch stage
um if you have to take if you have to
take a [ __ ]
um you know you have to it's in it's in
a Coke riddled rat pissed you know and I
was thought I was I was I was [ __ ]
all night long just throwing out leaders
of piss on my ass and just trying to
drink and drink and the next day I'm
like all right here I'm on stage I'm
like [ __ ] it let's go and then I have
you did your show like that yeah the
show I've seen no yours no I don't mean
the show I mean your show yeah on the
verge of [ __ ] yourself at any moment
as much as you jump around and run
around dive into the garage I still did
all that [ __ ] I still did all that [ __ ]
were you scared at any moment yes well I
was focused on that I started I was like
oh here we go y'all I I just you gotta
let them know hey I've had food
poisoning I've been [ __ ] my pants
all day here's my set and then right
after I did that I was like
song was playing I'm like
I'm sick right now here we go and I just
left the stage went around this corner
and was [ __ ] you know wrapping my
[ __ ] songs [ __ ] you know wiping
my [ __ ] like oh I hope all y'all you
know I'm doing a good job man going
through my verses and everything you
should save time
am I I was wearing shorts and so I
pulled the shorts down there was just
throw up and vomit of like four days
everywhere and I was sick as [ __ ] I was
like this is one of the worst worst
experiences in my pressure this story is
gonna make some people throw up and you
can't even throw up and I did that for
like seven shows in two or three days
like just like just like that I haven't
I mean knock on wood I've told we were
talking about it before I've never
it just goes away when you get on stage
usually you know usually yeah piss or a
[ __ ] you don't I don't care how long I'm
up there I don't feel it so this is what
happens to me I feel like that's got to
be crazy I feel like a submarine before
I go on stage everything just tightens
up my dick gets a little it's like I
call basketball dick you ever like
really when you do an athletic
performance or whatever your dick goes
in for like battle mode you know you
can't be out here just free you know
getting injured and [ __ ] you just can't
be out here you know no but um and and
everything tightens up and you go
underwater you know what I mean yeah I
get off stage
I'm just like oh I'll start farting
again and stuff my dick will get big
again and or regular sized or however
you know but um
yeah usually usually you tighten up and
you can get everything done
but not when you're really really sick
like that I couldn't should you have
canceled
yeah
like it was that bad
well I don't know looking about you're
[ __ ] on a toilet nothing came a bit
nothing came of this I wasn't discovered
no I can't get no [ __ ] fans from that
[ __ ] it was for no [ __ ] reason
whatsoever I should have canceled right
away should have just taken a flight
back but back then you're like ah you
know there's probably hopefully there's
some sort of record exactly in this
dumbass bar that I'm performing for in
for no reason
yeah definitely not worth it
what um
I wanted to ask you the the is that time
bomb tour different than
what you just talked about well Time
Bomb tour i i i i i i bear some
responsibility for that because I like
cat litter and cat [ __ ] so it wasn't
like a Tilapia at a restaurant like I
deserved that [ __ ] you know what I mean
I was at a party and it was really it
was really boring it was really boring
it was a really boring party I'm like yo
let's [ __ ] get weird somewhere else
and you know we got drunk and they catch
[ __ ] and then we were going through the
desert we had [ __ ] yeah it was just
kitty litter and I I don't you know I've
lived a lot of different lives you know
I'm not doing that I'm not doing that
anymore but I was on some jackass [ __ ]
like
if I was bored I'd be like even for the
party I'd be like watch this y'all and
I'll just take one for the team and
it'll go all the way up that was me
um and it started I did that in
done everything somewhere in Colorado
like Denver or something then the next
you know I was sick for a few days and
we toured through the Southwest well
you're eating [ __ ] and cat litter like
neither of those two could be well I'm
sure there's a little bit of [ __ ] in the
cat litter I mean I didn't take a chunk
of [ __ ] I think it was just I don't know
I was [ __ ] up yeah I mean sure yeah
and you know then our van broke down and
we were stuck in the desert while I was
[ __ ] behind like cactuses and [ __ ]
and wiping my ass with Stage towels
yeah that was
van broke down in the desert uh dude
dude um in the um
who in the uh tow truck it's like you
need a big ass tow truck for this he's
like I can take five of y'all there's
six of us one of us is staying in this
[ __ ] desert you know we're like
pulling straws and he's like well he
took like a bunch of dudes in the cab
and he was like [ __ ] it get in get in
the truck we're gonna put you on the
truck hide put your head down on the uh
in the van in the back of the truck and
he took took us there illegally and I
was just really [ __ ] drunk the whole
time and I had long hair
and then when we got to like San Diego I
buzzed it balled down the middle and so
I was sick as [ __ ] I was like nothing
matters anymore yeah and then we pulled
up to LA and one of the richest people
I've ever met is like a fan and he was
like I got you guys a
this hotel it's it's almost like near
Catalina or something we had a day off
and the van is fixed by now and we pull
out of this [ __ ] van
it's a classic [ __ ] nasty kid van
like come inside the van rust everywhere
it's white we pull up there's
Lamborghinis and Ferraris everywhere and
I step out I'm in a robe for some reason
don't give a [ __ ] about my life anymore
I'm like smoking menthols I have my hair
is like this and I step out with a
cigarette into this place and I'm like
it's the best it's the best hotel I've
ever seen in my entire life and it was
pretty gnarly and then in Santa Cruz we
got robbed completely everything taken
the whole the whole shebang how'd they
get you every instrument well we parked
and we got ice cream
on the pier they got they got us while
we were getting ice cream we're like
this is something
they work and we were having such a
pleasant day
yeah we're having such a pleasure you
tell you you tow a trailer with all your
[ __ ] in it is that what they win or they
got in that van they got in the van and
just took everything everything how many
guys
probably like it was a knock it was a
bang bang job and you didn't see all the
instruments were gone all the no they
were gone all the windows were down like
we took we took our time we pulled up
right in front of these [ __ ]
we saw them we're like oh these dudes
are grimy y'all crackheads all right see
ya peace have fun with all of our [ __ ]
it was dumb as [ __ ] changed the way we
think about touring
so I mean every computer every
instrument every [ __ ] speaker like
you know passports we were going up into
Canada afterwards like we lost
everything damn passports oh that's
dangerous clothes then you're like oh
[ __ ] well I gotta call this for the
Chargers then you're like oh man then it
really makes you think about just any
tiny little
Comfort creature comfort and life that
you need to do
so um we made it through that tour that
was one tour it was [ __ ] nuts
yeah
I don't trust anybody out there I don't
leave [ __ ] in my car nothing I know on
Melrose a lot of comedians left [ __ ] in
their car and he's homeless just go by
bash the window grab it go there goes my
laptop there goes my purse I'm like why
are you leaving your purse in plain
sight that's stupid yeah that's stupid
we did some stupid [ __ ] I mean it helps
now that we're in a bus it's like man
it's official we're up here we got we
got [ __ ] it locks it locks yeah no
one's no one knows who's on a bus right
and well you there's always someone on a
bus with some [ __ ] heat if it [ __ ]
need be you know and like no one's
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] and so it's I'm
really really thankful to be you know
official that wave touring the right way
and not doing all that other [ __ ]
anymore
um you also said you did you had a
recent death in your life too can we be
comfortable talking about that yeah no I
mean I [ __ ] posted about it
so that was that was my little buddy
pilot he was a I dumped my dog uh German
shorthair pointer how long did you have
them he was 11. so I was kind of young I
don't know he just hit him when he was
baby maybe eight weeks to to to you know
11 years and he was like he was one
family member that I put in the
spotlight and everybody knew him like
you know if I was walking out the dog
you know people shot oh what's up pilot
like yeah yeah we had a that's what I do
with Princess Zone yeah got a [ __ ]
dog named princess you know my daughter
said to me all day she goes kind of over
the princess stuff and I was like yeah
you're getting older and you're over the
princess stuff she goes yeah I go just
just so you know we have a dog named
princess
she named her that she named her
Princess Lily Rose and I kept saying
listen can we just call her that but
princess is her title yeah princess
something title it's not a yeah and
she's like that's her name and I was
like you did it whatever you didn't pick
my battle you did it so now she's
Princess Lily Rose yeah and I'm outside
going princess I'm yelling that [ __ ] you
must be like a little [ __ ] man I'm a
dad I don't give a [ __ ] I'm a dad it's
over I'm a dad I have no dignity [ __ ]
what do you think this is man Princess
I'm doing that [ __ ] out there with no
shame what are you looking at
[ __ ] some tiny whities I'll
still fight you I'll still fight you um
so pilot was like we we have we have
like a a dog clothing line called
co-pilot you know like people knew knew
him and [ __ ] and so I post about him a
lot and he just got this cancer growth
in his like you know in his skull like
near near his face like inner outside of
his head and I just went super quick man
and I was like I don't wanna I don't
wanna
I wanted to get someone to come in
eventually
he was he hated the [ __ ] uh vet
anytime we went in there he knew he knew
what time it was like he hated that [ __ ]
I'm like I'm not going to take him to
the vet for his last
uh experience in life I was like I want
I want someone to come to my house and
[ __ ] kill them
and we were calling people we're like
well how do you how do you do this like
when is the right time like I don't
really want you to come yet he's still
kind of walking around but you know what
did you know
he was one I knew when I had to uh carry
him down like three stairs when he was
when he wasn't he was having trouble
going to the bathroom then I was like
[ __ ]
and it happened real quick then I was
like maybe now's the time you know I
don't want to kill a dog early if he's
still kind of like having fun with you
you know and I think I waited too long
because it I'm drastically calling
everybody like you need to come here now
I never knew I would be in that
situation like come kill my dog right
now you know and they came over oh man
you found somebody that day yeah and
they were [ __ ] amazing they're like
this is what's gonna happen one shot to
do something and then the other two you
know knocked the heart out and um it's
three shots two two so yeah one one man
is that at first I was right by his side
after the first shot where in your home
right in the front door
it was right he was he was stuck there
like that was just where wherever he was
yeah he was on his little dog uh bed and
he was just right near the front door
and she was like the first shot he might
like breathe or whatever oh first shot
he was like oh
I heard him make that noise
I was like oh no I was like I was like
I'm right here I'm right here I'm just
holding him and he's like are you by
yourself is that anyone else man my
girl's with me just right there with
them and he is like screaming like a
human and I've never heard that before
in my life
and and then eventually though he like
calmed down again his eyes were open
and she was like okay and you know he
was nice and calm I was right by the
side whispering in his ear and stuff oh
you know like you've been such a good
boy man so thankful it comes in and I'm
like
I had my hand on his heart and I was
like that's it like and then now he's
gone that was the second shot yeah the
second shot was a lot quieter a lot more
peaceful and how long
the whole process was like 10 minutes
like can you really feel the heart slow
out of yourself the heart slows down no
I was right there I was right I was like
almost I'm gonna be right here with you
the whole way like I want to know
everything and it was and you felt it
stop
damn I was like that's it
and then
you've wrapped them up in the blanket
and then I've carried them
right out to her car and where'd you
bury him ashes oh you got his ashes yeah
and so
yeah I was carrying him my girl's like
his his foot his foot is out the blanket
it was like it's like way over there and
I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm like
whatever man I felt but it felt good to
like say goodbye in such a thorough way
and you're there too I was right out
here on the road and you had to come
back and hear that news or I was on a
road like leading up like I was like
he's in bad shape I shot him no I shot a
music video
I saw a really sad music video it's
gonna come out sometime next year
whenever it's called tombstones and it's
a sad ass video in the middle of the
video I got the news saying he was
terminal and so
they were like let's keep are you okay
do you want to keep shooting I'm like
well what do I need to do make a sad
face they're like yeah I'm like let's
[ __ ] go and so when you see this
video come out it's probably it's
probably gonna be a long time because
we're like six months in advance we're
working so hard but when that video of
tombstones comes out you'll be like oh
damn that dude just got news his dog is
gonna die so that's interesting but it
was such a good goodbye to him it was so
thorough and [ __ ] sad so
heartbreaking
that afterwards I was like
okay like I wasn't
I was like at peace because I knew I
just saw the whole process there was no
like second guessing anything like I was
I was pretty good pretty quick
afterwards
yeah how about you how many kids do you
have you comfortable talking about that
yeah I've only only on your show I got I
think I might have had a second one
since yeah
yeah I talked to him were you were
pregnant yep so how old's your oldest
two and a half right now okay so you
haven't really had to tell no okay how
do you explain that yeah where's pilot
he still goes away he's dead no yeah
he's dead he died he's not he's not with
us he's dead oh Pilot's dead Pat is dead
yeah he doesn't know what that means but
he's gone he's dead he's not here he's
dead are you gonna get another dog
eventually I'm I gotta have a dog I'm a
dog person yeah there's just too much
going on right now I I know it I got a
lot on my plate dude I don't need to I
don't want to [ __ ] ass dog that I don't
like that is like running around doing
[ __ ] I want to be able to train it or
whatever you know like I don't want
having a nasty dog you don't like on top
of a family I've I've I know people with
shitty dogs like that [ __ ] sucks they
do suck so I'm like I knew we had a
cousin one time and they were so shitty
the dog jumped the fence and left I'm
not even bullshitting it ran away you
don't hear that much dogs usually ran
away from you
I see him out here with homeless people
all the time my cousin was such a piece
of [ __ ] this dog ran the [ __ ] away I was
like that dog knows what's up
deserve that [ __ ] all right so here's
what I want to ask you now as a dad
you're a rapper
you're touring all the time what do you
want for your kids
I'm certainly not growing up the way you
did none of them none of our kids are
growing up I'm on track to do what I
want what I set out to do with them is
them just not needing to have to be
tough
you know like I want them to be
resilient as [ __ ] but I don't want them
to have to [ __ ] I have to shank
[ __ ] you know like just
mentally be as nasty as I've been coming
up you know what I mean like
um because you get into trouble and
whatever like I want them to be able to
um
flourish and do whatever they want like
follow their interests you know what I
mean and not have to [ __ ] worry about
like
the [ __ ] that I did you know and not
having like I mean there's days waking
up like man I I think I need to whoop
this dude's ass I think I need to prove
to these people or I need to do that
like I think I would like them to wake
up and be like um I can't wait to go to
[ __ ] basketball practice or something
you know like
yeah there's days I would wake up like
where's my meal coming from today where
am I sleeping tonight my my kids never
got to worry about that [ __ ] yeah I mean
my mom
that definitely have memories of popcorn
for dinner you know like that this is it
you know lots of hamburger boiled uh hot
dogs and stuff like that but um
yeah that's it's not going to be like
that for them already
you know so I don't know what will
happen with some teenagers and [ __ ]
especially when they're when they see
what the [ __ ] all the videos of the
[ __ ] pops online doing all this wild
[ __ ] but you know then again I could
tell them like man like my circumstances
were different and you know
and they have episodes like this to
listen to to really figure out who you
are too if they don't have discussion
I'll [ __ ] tell them yeah you know
what I mean like you're straight with
them yeah I mean I know my son's gonna
be [ __ ] stronger than me but if he's
smarter than me then I'm [ __ ] you know
what I mean then then I'll probably just
go out for a carton of cigarettes and
never come back
you know what I mean like what's gonna
happen if you get in an argument with
with your child about some sort of like
and then they like box you in a corner
or something my daughter already does it
means god damn it but you said I said
you know what I'm gonna do
because she's not wrong either I don't
listen to me
I'm gonna start repeating back what you
said and then every time you say
something wrong I'm a c and eventually
we're gonna hit the point where you
[ __ ] can't stand it either that's
what we're gonna do yeah and she'll do
that to me but you said but you said and
I'm like
yeah I always want to try to have these
conversations I'm like all right because
I I promised her two things I would
never say because I said so
I hated that I hated being treated like
that as a kid that just means for no
[ __ ] reason other than I want to be
dominant over power tripping and I don't
why why not just tell me okay because I
can't lose
because I care about you right because
this is what and the other thing I
promised her and I won't do it is um
lick a napkin and [ __ ] wipe her face
I [ __ ] it all my [ __ ] god she's like
Mom does that to me like oh that [ __ ]
stank spit all up on your face I ain't
gonna do that to you my sister told me
she was like the number one thing she
wanted and I man it resonated with me so
I take it too she was like I just grown
up I don't want to have to [ __ ] clip
coupons coupons and just you know
balance a checkbook and add every single
penny take things off of the cart and
and you know because that's that's how
we went grocery shopping for you know
the whole time and and that really
pissed her off and we're not pissed her
off but it was it's it's yeah it's sad
to take food away you know when you're
grocery shopping and that happened every
time I wouldn't go grocery shopping
there's always something you know this
is we're buying seventy four dollars
I've seventy four dollars cash here or
I've seventy four dollars in my checking
account my mama and then she'd have to
balance that [ __ ] and like boom that's
it you need to be careful you can't
[ __ ] go one penny over or That's Just
Bounce that's you know
so it's good to be like
not have to check prices and groceries I
still check the prices and [ __ ]
everything else you know I'm not buying
no [ __ ] 70 t-shirt or something like
that but as far as like if some oranges
are a little you know but
so that that's a good goal too
I always was embarrassed that I had
holes in my socks underwear [ __ ] like
that and I I promised myself to this day
I mean my sock drawer is overflowing
like a [ __ ] and if I pull one up
and it's got a hole up on the side of it
is gone yeah it's gone like the freshest
cleanest [ __ ] my dog oh no not like a
fresh clean pair of socks I I read
somewhere the Foo Fighters I feel like
had that in their Rider like everywhere
they went it was a fresh pair of socks
that makes sense it feels good to put
your feet in a fresh pair of [ __ ]
socks yeah
[ __ ] yeah I'm with it
um dude thank you for coming back on
here I appreciate you coming in I can't
wait to watch the video yeah there's
video this time yeah that's cool man yo
I'm very very thankful to have you as a
friend man I'm happy to be back here
every time this is why my boy Barry D's
what's up Barry he's the one that
connected us originally he made a little
uh graphic with your music in it and so
many people started yeah that's that's
the uh my manager was like yo check this
[ __ ] out yeah Barry D's Oh my Jesus uh
it does great graphics all that [ __ ] and
that and then I started realizing like
how many fans we had in common I was
really pleasantly surprised at our
worlds crossed like that yeah I saw that
[ __ ] and it felt the same thing yeah I
was like damn
and then you all came out to Comedy
story tonight you're going back again
tonight you're gonna see good shows yeah
well thank you you don't want to promote
anything and unplug your social nothing
you know nothing there's nothing out
there just [ __ ] yeah you don't have
to
that's fine with me I don't know like
when it is coming out like yeah yeah my
manager is like this he was like look
man
if he asks you can you just at least put
up your social or something like that it
actually does have a uh
um effect like it does have an effect
and I was like no promises it's that
Prof gambo right yeah gompo gompo
g-a-m-p-o
damn it I was gonna say no but you're
saying it at the very wait that [ __ ] out
what you want man like
really good listeners
I'm really [ __ ] good too go see him
live I mean your [ __ ] live shows are
absolutely insane uh and when I brought
my neighbor Jen came that night Kim
Congdon wine shank they all came and I
was like listen just trust me on this
come and you'll see and they were they
loved you I'm glad I disappointed that
that show was the [ __ ] it was a great
show yeah so just yeah put me on Spotify
or something give us a couple songs a
try
um I got songs with people and other
rappers too and [ __ ] but yeah you're
great I'm just happy to come here and
talk to you dude you're welcome anytime
thank you for coming back oh man and as
always Ryan sickler on all social media
Ryan sickler.com subscribe to YouTube
because it does matter talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what is this dude
so you can there's a lot of good [ __ ] in
there
you can learn
you can learn how to press record
uh you can even yo I thought we got all
these you just [ __ ] over here
you can pair you can pair it'll teach
you how to pair video with audio oh wow
um you can turn off on and off your
cameras this is great man thank you for
the gift we really uh we're gonna we're
gonna learn how to do that here hell
yeah yeah man we'll get that video
rolling appreciate it